Okay. Okay. Guten Abend. Guten Abend. Ich bin Dr. René Sertrück und für Sie zustande Gast in dieser Station.
Ich würde mit Ihnen heute das MSG-Spräch durchführen. Bevor wir anfangen, muss ich Ihre persönliche Daten aufnehmen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden? Ja. Okay. Super. Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Frithelm Bering.
Bering.
Herr Bering. Können Sie Ihre Vor- und Nachnamen buster bieren?
Frithelm schreibt sich F-R-I-E-D-H-E-L-M.
Frithelm und Bering B-E-H-R-I-N-G.
Herr Bering. Wie heißen Sie?
53. Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 4. Februar 1970.
1970. Wie groß sind Sie?
1,84 m.
Herr Bering. Was führt Sie sonst?
Ich habe seit einigen Stunden, ich schätze seit 10 Stunden, sehr stark Bauchschmerzen.
Was tut überall wem Bauch?
Die Bauchschmerz überall.
Wie haben die Schmerzen begonnen?
Das hat sich langsam gesteigert.
Haben die Schmerzen sich im Laufe der Zeit verschlechtert?
Ja, die sind schlechter, schlimmer geworden.
Ich habe heute Abend gesagt, jetzt muss ich ins Krankenhaus.
Das halte ich nicht mehr aus.
Können Sie Ihre Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzschmerzschmerz von 1 bis 10 einschätzen?
Das bedeutet sehr leichte Schmerz.
Das bedeutet unerzweckliche Schmerz.
8 bis 9.
Herr Bering, ich merke, dass Sie sehr stark Schmerzen haben.
Ich würde Sie fragen, soll ich Ihnen eine Schmerzschmerzschmerz geben?
Können Sie Ihre Schmerzen bis zu Ende unserer Gespräche aushalten?
Wenn es nicht zu lange dauert, dann kann ich das noch aushalten.
Es dauert ca. 15 oder 20 Minuten.
Haben Sie dagegen Medikamente eingenommen?
Ja, ich habe vor vielleicht 5 Stunden mal eine Paracetamol-Tablette genommen.
Aber das hat überhaupt nichts geändert.
Paracetamol hat nicht geholfen.
Eine Tablette?
Eine Tablette.
Wie viele Milligramm haben Sie eingenommen?
Stand drauf für Erwachsene.
Können Sie Ihre Schmerzen beschreiben?
Sind die Schmerzen z.B. stehend, Kolikartig, dumpf?
Sie sind mehr dumpf.
Und vielleicht manchmal etwas wie eine Welle.
Aber hauptsächlich dumpf.
Okay.
Manchmal wellen für mich.
Sind die Schmerzen dauerhaft oder vorübergegangen?
Die Schmerzen sind immer da.
Wenn es so manchmal eine Welle kommt, dann werden sie noch mal etwas stärker.
Dann gehen Sie wieder etwas zurück. Aber Sie sind immer sehr stark da.
Immer da.
Gibt es eine bestimmte Auslöser für die Schmerzen?
Die Schmerzen sind immer noch etwas stärker.
Ich habe keine Apetite.
Ich habe nur ein bisschen Tee getrunken.
Ich kann auch nicht gut sitzen.
Das tut dann noch mehr weh.
Ich muss mich immer ein bisschen hinlegen.
Das ist das Beste.
Wenn Sie vielleicht liegen, ist das am besten.
Ich ziehe dann die Knie etwas an.
Ich stelle die Knie etwas auf.
Dann ist es etwas besser.
Aber immer noch schlimm.
Sie haben gesagt, Sie leiden unter Apetitlosigkeit.
Sie haben keine Apetite.
Also, indem ich die Schmerzen habe, habe ich nichts gegessen.
Dann habe ich keinen Hunger.
Ich habe sogar auch 3 Mal erbrochen.
Ist Ihnen über im Moment?
Ja, auch.
Aber irgendwie sage ich mir, ich habe gar nichts mehr im Magen.
Viel kann da nicht mehr rauskommen.
Das war alles jetzt so gelblicher Schleim, der da rauskam.
Das erbrochen sieht schleimig aus.
Gelb, etwas gelb und schleimig.
Das ist das, das ich habe.
Also, wenn ich mich hinstelle und rumgehe, dann tut es noch mehr weh.
Am besten ist, wenn ich mich hinlege.
Okay, alles klar.
Okay, noch etwas.
Ich habe noch etwas.
Ich treibe die Schmerzen irgendwo hin auch.
Herr Bezig.
Ein bisschen in den Rücken.
Ein bisschen in den Rücken?
Und vielleicht so ein bisschen in die linke Kälte?
Aber mehr in den Rücken?
In den Rücken und linken Kälte.
Okay.
Herr Bezig.
Herr Biring, fühlen Sie sich fühlbar?
Nein, nicht wirklich.
Ich verstehe Schwitzen, das denke ich kommt auch vom Schmerz,
dass ich so schwitzen muss.
Sie schwitzen?
Ja.
Und Sie haben?
Ich denke, das kommt durch den Schmerz.
Ach so, danke.
Okay, okay.
Okay, wegen der Schmerzen schwitzen Sie, oder?
Hab ich richtig verstanden.
Wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich.
Das ist eine Erklärung von mir.
Okay, okay.
Leiden Sie unter Nachtschweiß?
Normalerweise nicht.
Normalerweise im Moment?
Letzter Nacht war das stärker, da hatte ich ja die Schmerzen auch schon.
Haben Sie Stilfrost?
Nein.
Haben Sie in den letzten Zeit ab oder zu genommen?
Also, ich habe Gewicht schon weniger in den letzten zwei Jahren.
Wie viel ungefähr?
Wie viel habe ich mich in den letzten zwei Jahren, so schätze ich, 8 kg.
8 kg.
Die letzten zwei Jahre?
Ja.
Sie haben 8 kg in den letzten zwei Jahren abgenommen.
Okay.
Danke viel.
Ist Ihnen schwindelig?
Nein.
Okay.
Und dann kreiten Schwierigkeiten beim Wasserlassen auf?
Oder beim Stuhlgang?
Haben Sie Durchfall, Verstoffung?
Also Wasserlassen, ich muss in der Regel einmal in der Nacht auf Toilette Wasser lassen.
Jetzt in den letzten Stunden habe ich wenig Wasser gelassen,
ich glaube, weil ich auch wenig getrunken habe.
Okay.
Normalerweise ist Stuhlgang regelmäßig, der letzte war jetzt ungefähr vor 24 Stunden.
Ich komme gleich.
Habt ihr das?
Sie müssen einmal nachts an Wasserlassen aufwachen.
Ja, wichtig.
Normalerweise kann ich wieder gut einschlafen.
Okay.
Und ihr Urinmenge ist weniger geworden.
Ja.
Urin?
Ja, aber ich glaube, weil ich in den letzten Stunden viel weniger getrunken habe,
weil wir so übel war und weil sich so Schmerzen hatte.
Okay.
Wie viel trinken Sie Wasser im Moment?
Auch hier habe ich vielleicht in den letzten 3-4 Stunden,
habe ich vielleicht 1-2 Gläser getrunken, höchstens.
Einfach.
Sie haben gesagt, Ihre lästige Stuhlgang war vor einem Tag.
Haben Sie Verstoffung?
Nein.
Okay.
Wie sieht Ihre lästige Stuhl aus?
Zum Beispiel blutig oder wie?
Vor einem Tag, da kann ich mich nicht mehr daran erinnern, wie der war.
Okay, und dann?
Okay, wie war die Konsistenz Ihres lästiges Stuhls?
Was heißt Konsistenz?
Zum Beispiel, Bewässerung oder Fest oder?
Nein, das war normal.
Liebten Sie unter ähnlichen Beschwerden schon einmal bereit?
Ja, ich habe in den letzten 2 Jahren solche Schmerzen,
habe meine Frau gefragt, sie sagte, das wäre 3-mal gewesen,
dass ich solche ähnlichen Schmerzen hatte,
aber die waren nicht ganz so stark wie jetzt.
Sie haben dann immer so 3-4 Tage, dann wurde das langsam besser,
aber das habe ich jetzt schon einige Male gehabt.
Okay, in den nächsten 2 Jahren haben Sie ähnliche Beschwerden gelitten,
und dann hat es so weiter bis 4 Tage gedauert.
3-4 Tage, aber es war nie ganz so stark,
diesmal ist es viel stärker.
Nicht so stark, okay.
Was haben Sie damals gemacht?
Zum Beispiel zum Arztbesuch oder?
Nein, das eine Mal, da waren wir verreist im Urlaub,
und da habe ich dann nur im Bett gelegen, 3-4 Tage lang,
und dann wurde es besser.
Ich bin damit bisher noch nie zum Arzt gegangen.
Okay, verstanden.
Waren Sie in den nächsten Zeit im Ausland?
Ja, wir waren in Italien vor einem halben Jahr,
waren wir eine Woche in Italien,
aber sonst waren wir nicht im Ausland.
Okay, klar.
Aber ab der Größe, okay.
Okay Herr Behring,
sind bei Ihnen allergen oder Unterträglichkeiten bekannt?
Nein, keine allergen.
Okay,
rauchen Sie, Herr Behring?
Ja.
Wie viel Zigarette rauchen Sie täglich?
Ja, schon eine Schachtel.
Eine Schachtel?
Eine Schachtel, und das schon jetzt ziemlich lange.
Ich würde sagen seit 30 Jahren,
fast 35 Jahre, würde ich sagen.
Ja, es wäre gesünder, wenn Sie weniger rauchen.
Ja, das sagen wir alle.
Okay, trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, ja, ja.
Alkohol, so 2 Flaschen Bierabend,
und dann auch mal 2-3 Schnäpfe.
Trinken Sie jede Abend? Ja.
Und danach trinken Sie noch etwas?
Schnaps.
Schnaps, okay.
Schnaps, Probo oder pro Tag?
Pro Tag.
Pro Tag auch.
Pro Tag, pro Tag.
Sie konsumieren relativ mehr Alkohol, ja.
Darf ich fragen,
ob Sie Drogen nehmen?
Nein, habe ich noch nie.
Herr Beading,
jetzt würde ich Sie nach Ihrer
folgischen Frage leiten Sie an chronischen
Erkrankungen, wie zum Beispiel
Eskalkrankheit, Wolltuchdruck
oder...
Also ich habe seit einigen Jahren,
hat mir gesagt, ich hätte zu hohes Kohlesterin,
nehme ich ein Medikament,
und dann habe ich auch noch hohen Blutbrück,
seit...
Gegen hohe Blutvertz,
warschen Medikament, nehmen Sie ein.
Simvastatin heißt das.
Ich pleite 20 hinter.
20 Milligramm, einmal im Monat.
Einmal morgens.
Und Sie leiten einen Blutdruck?
Ja, hoher Blutdruck, dann nehme ich
circa fünf Jahre, nehme ich da Tabletten ein.
fünf Jahre.
Warschen Medikamente nehmen Sie ein.
Das Mittel heißt einmal Ramiepril.
April, fünf steht dahinter,
dann nehme ich eine Tablette morgens und eine Tablette abends,
und dann heißt ein Medikament noch
Fugose mit.
Dahinter steht 20,
dann nehme ich eine morgens von.
20 Milligramm, einmal morgens.
Okay, haben noch andere Erkrankungen?
Ich hatte vor einem Jahr
ein Herzkatheter-Untersuchung.
Herzkatheter, warum?
Da wurde ich auch behandelt,
weil ich Herzrhythmostörungen habe.
Und da wurde das mit
Katheter behandelt, und es wurde
im Herzen was vereist.
Vereist? Was meinst du?
Vereist, also
danach waren die Rhythmostörungen weg.
Aha, okay.
Hat gesagt, er hat etwas mit Kälte behandelt,
vereist.
Okay, und dann
ist Ihre
Erkrankung besser geworden oder handelt worden?
Die ist,
seitdem ist das in Ordnung.
Okay, Herr Beering,
wurden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Ja, als Kind wurde ich am
Leistenbruch operiert, rechts.
Da war ich vielleicht 9 Jahre alt.
Und ich hatte dann
eine Erkrankung,
die ich hatte,
ich hatte dann
einen Sturz
beim, weiß ich nicht,
Fußball spielen, oder so, da habe ich mir
ein Handwurzelknochen gebrochen.
Kanbein, das Kanbein.
Und das musste dann auch operiert werden.
Das hat ziemlich lange gedauert.
Aber insgesamt gesehen ist das ganz gut geworden.
Nach dem Fußball-Match, Fußballspielen?
Ja, das war beim Fußballspielen, da bin ich auf die Hand gefallen.
Okay.
Kaftbein operiert.
Ist das alles?
Nein, ich habe dann, also
Operationen nicht, aber ich habe dann insgesamt glaube ich
dreimal eine Magenspiegelung gehabt.
Ich habe häufig 12 Fingerdarmgeschwüre gehabt.
Okay.
Also gegen
12 Fingerdarmgeschwür
wurden sie
dreimal eine Magenspiegelung durchgeführt.
Da wurde auch eine Magenspiegelung gemacht.
Und dann habe ich Medikamente genommen
und dann wurde mir immer gesagt, ja,
das hängt wahrscheinlich damit zusammen,
weil ich so viel Schnaps tränke.
Okay.
Aber im Moment,
leiden Sie an...
Das heißt,
die
die Fingerdarmgeschwür
wurde mit den Kommentaren behandelt.
Ja.
Okay.
Was sind Sie von Beruf?
Ich arbeite im Straßenbau.
Straßen?
Weiter, arbeite im Straßenbau. Ich baue Autobahnen.
Ja, Straßenbau.
Okay.
Wie ist Ihre Job?
Ja, sehr anstrengend.
Darberlich sehr anstrengend.
Es geht ganz schön.
Ich werde ganz schön beansprucht von der Muskulatur her,
vom Rücken her.
Ja, das ist richtig.
Ja, sehr anstrengend.
Okay.
Ich habe zwei Kinder.
Die sind 26 und 28 Jahre alt.
Und die haben beide etwas Asthma.
Aha, okay.
Mit Mais
und so ist das, glaube ich,
sehr ganz gut zufrieden,
dass das ganz gut geht.
Okay, gut.
Ja, ich habe das.
Okay.
Treiben Sie Sport?
Nein.
Früher habe ich etwas Fußball gespielt,
aber das ist schon lange her.
Da war ich vielleicht 20, 25 Jahre alt.
Okay.
Habt ihr alles?
Ja, ich habe das.
Wie viel Leben ihr werdet?
Die Mutter lebt noch, die ist 80.
Die Mutter hat etwas Alterszucker.
Alterszucker?
Ja, und hatte vor, glaube ich, 20 Jahren mal,
wurde sie an der Gallenblase operiert.
Mein Vater,
der ist mit 60 Jahren schon verstorben.
Und die Mutter leidet unter
Leidung an
Zuckerkrankheit.
Alterszucker, ja.
Alterszucker.
Ja, ich habe das.
Ich habe das.
Alterszucker, ja.
Es gibt den Unterschied,
zwischen Alterszucker und Zuckerkrankheit.
Ja, es gibt den Zucker bei Jugendlichen.
Juvenile Diabetes.
Ja.
Eins Diabetes und der Zucker, der erst im Alter auftritt.
Meistens ein Typ 2 Diabetes.
Ja, okay.
Sagen wir in Deutschland, sprechen wir von Alterszucker.
Also im Alter, im höheren Alter.
Das ist ein Typ 2.
Aber Junges Diabetes.
Okay, danke.
Ich habe noch eine Schwester, die ist 52 Jahre alt.
Die ist vor einem Jahr, hatte sie Brustkrebs
und ist da operiert worden und hatte Chemotherapie bekommen.
Ja, die war die Nachricht.
Und die war bisher alle gut.
Super.
Ihre Schwester wurde operiert.
Und dann vor einem Jahr mit Chemotherapie bekommen.
Ja, Operation und Chemotherapie.
Okay.
Herr Beering, ich glaube,
ich habe alle wichtige Informationen gesammelt.
Haben Sie noch eine kleine Frage?
Haben Sie noch Fragen?
Oder gibt es etwas da, das Sie nicht sagen?
Was kann das sein, diese starken Schmerzen?
Kann mir das nicht erinnern?
Ja.
Herr Beering, ich gehe von dem Verdacht
auf eine
mesenteriellen Fart.
Das heißt aus,
ich habe eine kleine Frage,
die ich mir nicht erinnern würde.
Es könnte sein,
dass einige Fests im Bauch
Verengung ist.
Und deswegen,
das sagt vielleicht die Symptome,
aber das ist eine Verdachtdiagnose.
Und deswegen, ich würde Sie jetzt über weitere Schritte informieren.
Zuerst möchte ich Sie körperlich untersuchen.
Und dann in den Blut abnehmen.
Und dann,
ich würde röntgen
Bauch durchführen.
Und natürlich Urtaschall möchte ich machen.
Und
gegen die Gegenbeumfreien
vielleicht brauchen wir noch weitere
Procedere.
Aber je nach Befund können wir
wieder darüber sprechen.
Kann ich jetzt etwas trinken
oder etwas essen, wenn ich möchte?
Im Moment müssen Sie
nicht essen und trinken.
Sie müssen nüchtern sein.
Aber natürlich, ich gebe Ihnen
Flüssigkeit
durch den Gefäß.
Also, okay.
Und bitte warten Sie kurz in Wattsüber.
Okay.
Ich rufe vielleicht auf.
Haben Sie jetzt etwas Zeit und gibt es von den
Kolleginnen und Kollegen Fragen oder Ergänzungen?
Ist der Fall damit gelöst?
Haben Sie Brustschmerzen?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Ist Ihnen
Haltfarbperenderungen abgefallen?
Nein, das bin ich aufgefallen.
Leiten Sie unter
Erlegungen?
Manchmal schon, aber jetzt nicht besonders.
Seitdem ich die Schmerzen habe,
habe ich die Schmerzen nicht aufgefallen.
Ich sehe eine Frage, wo genau sind Ihre Bauchschmerzen?
Steht da unten?
Im Anfang habe ich gesagt, die sind überall.
Vielleicht etwas stärker
so im oberen Bauch.
So unterhalb der Rippen.
Vielleicht mehr auf der linken Seite.
Ich habe die Frage, wo genau sind Ihre Bauchschmerzen?
Aber sonst tut mir der ganze Bauch weh.
Sind Sie schmerzend mit dem ersten Verwundung?
Also ich habe jetzt ja in den letzten Stunden gar nicht mehr gegessen,
weil ich keinen Appetit hatte und mir übel war.
Ich habe auch dreimal erbrochen.
Ich traue mich gar nicht mehr richtig zu essen.
Aber ich habe auch wie gesagt, ich habe keinen Hunger.
Haben Sie Atemnot?
Nein.
Schliessendsthin vorständig gegeben?
Ich habe, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere,
immer wieder Tätanus.
Impfungen bekommen Wunsch-Tar-Kampf,
weil ich häufig mal so kleine Arbeitsunfälle habe
beim Arbeit.
Er sagt der Arzt zu mir, das ist eine Besicherung.
Ich habe drei wundere Impfungen gemacht.
Jetzt überlege ich mir, ob ich im Herbst,
jetzt im November nochmal eine neue Impfung mache.
Vergesst nicht das,
weil das ist sehr wichtig für Sie.
Ich bin da.
Guten Tag Herr Oberrath.
Wenn Sie kurz Zeit hätten, würde ich Ihnen sagen,
dass Sie eine neue Impfung haben.
Ich würde mich überlegen,
wenn Sie kurz Zeit hätten,
würde ich gerne eine neue Patientin vorstellen.
Ja, habe ich.
Das freut mich.
Mein Name ist Enes Artur, Dr. Enes.
Es geht um Friedhelm Beering,
der 53 Jahre alt,
1,84 m groß,
73 kg schwer sei.
Er ist
bei uns, wegen 3-10 Stunden,
starker
Dufföse
zu nehmenden Schmerzen
im
überall Bauch.
Insgesamt abdomen.
Insgesamt abdomen vor.
Die Schmerzen seien langsam
aufgetreten
und seien dauerhaft.
Im Laufe der Zeit
seien die Schmerzen verschlimmer.
Dem Patientin zufolge
ist die Intensität der Schmerzen
auf einer Schmerzskala
bei 8-9.
Und dagegen habe
der Patient ein Tablet Paracetamol
eingenommen,
der nicht geholfen habe.
Ja, ohne Wirkung.
Herr Beering ist
ein 53-jähriger Patient,
der sich bei uns
mit akuten, abdominellen Schmerzen
vorstellte.
Die Schmerzen bestehen seit
circa 10 Stunden
und werden vom Patientin als
diffus und dumpf
und teilweise wellenförmig beschrieben.
Mit einer Schmerzintensität
von 8-9.
Ein sobald es intensitiert, von 8 bis 9.
Okay.
Der Patient beschrieb, die Schmerzen dumpf
und manchmal wellenförmig.
Und die Schmerzen würden
in den Rücken und in die linke Schulter ausgestrahlen.
Okay.
Und wegen Schmerzen
leidete er unter Inappetanz.
Und deswegen
könne der Patient nicht gut sitzen,
dass der Patient hinlegt,
verbessert sich der Schmerz.
Ja, oder der Schmerz
verstärkt sich beim Sitzen
im Liegen, in der Rückenlage
hat der Patient
eine gewisse Erleichterung oder eine gewisse
Verbesserung des Schmerzes.
Und
der Patient
habe naus her
und deswegen habe er
3-mal erbruschen.
Der das Erbruschen
habe gelb und schleimig
ausgesehen.
Ja, Womitus.
Der Patient berichtet über naus her
3-malige Womitus.
Das Erbrochene
wird als gelb schleimig beschrieben.
Das Erbruschen wird gelb und schleimig?
Das Erbruschen wird als gelb und schleimig
oder gelb schleimig beschrieben.
Die Farbe gelb und die Konsistenz
oder das es ist schleimig.
Gut.
Und der Patient hat der Patient
Blut erbrochen?
Nein, kein Blut.
Nein, kein Blut, sondern gelb
Farbe hier.
Also kein Blut?
Und auch, ja, genau.
Wann war der letzte Stuhlgang beim Patient?
Der nächste Schützl war vor
einem Tag.
Er war vor einem Tag.
Und auch der Patient
leide unter Nachtschweiz.
Und es ist auch völlig, dass er
8 kg in den
letzten 2 Jahre abgenommen haben.
Der Patient, kann man sagen,
berichtet über eine Gewichtsabnahme
von ca. 8 kg in den letzten
2 Jahre.
Genau.
Hat der Patient schon mal derartige Schmerzen gehabt?
Ja, der Patient
erlittet schon
eine Schmerz
vor 2 Jahren
oder in den letzten 2 Jahren.
Und wie oft ungefähr hatte er
Schmerzattacken-Schmerzebisonen?
Einmal oder fünfmal?
Ich habe nicht verstanden.
Ich glaube, der Patient berichtet,
dass er innerhalb der letzten 2 Jahre
insgesamt 3 Mal von solcher Schmerzen hatte.
Ja, 3 Mal Social Schmerzen hat, aber
aber sie waren nie bisher so stark.
Genau, diese Attacken
waren nicht so stark.
Genau, gut.
Es dauerte, es haben 3-4 Tage
angedauert.
Ist der Patient diesbezüglich schon einmal
ärztlich untersucht worden?
Die Schmerzen haben
selbst geheilt.
Na ja, sind nach 3-4 Tagen
spontan?
Ja, die Patienten sind schon erst nicht gegangen.
Okay, gut.
Hat der Patient
chronische Grunderkrankungen?
Ja, vor Erkrankungen
leide der Patient an,
wo ist das?
Ich habe geließe
Hypercholesterinämie.
Hypercholesterinämie
seit einigen Jahren.
Und dagegen nehme er
20 Milligramm
einmal morgens.
Außerdem leide er
an Artrella hypertonie seit 5 Jahren.
Und dagegen nehme er
5 Milligramm einmal morgens und einmal abends.
Und auch nehme er
20 Milligramm einmal morgens.
Okay, gibt es sonstige
Ereignisse im
Patientenleben?
Ja, genau.
Der Patient habe schon an
vor Hofsfilmern gelitten.
Und wurde sie
einen Herzkatheter
eingelegt oder durchgeführt?
Und gleichzeitig
wurden sie
eine
Eisungstherapie durchgeführt.
Vor einem Jahr, der Patient berichtet über
eine Katheter-Aplation
mittels Cryo-Technik.
Cryo-Aplation vor einem Jahr,
die wohl erfolgreich verlaufen ist.
Ja, genau.
Diese Krankheit wurde behandelt.
Erfolgsreich behandelt.
Ich kann auch sagen, der Patient berichtet über eine Katheter-Aplation
mit Cryo-Technik,
die erfolgreich
verlaufen ist.
Ja, und
gibt es Operationen?
Ja, als Operation.
Nach dem
Fußballspiel
habe der Patient gestürzt.
Ja.
Nach einem Fußballspiel
hat er eine Fraktur
von Skafoid.
Ja.
Und deswegen wurde er
operiert.
Bei der Patient
wurde eine Skafoid-Fraktur.
Eine Skafoid-Fraktur.
Durch eine Sportverletzung.
Erfolgsreich operiert.
Und fern
fügt der Patient hinzu,
dass er
3-mal ein Doskopie durchgeführt.
Aber der Patient hatte in der Kindheit noch ein OP?
Ja.
Als Kindheit
war es ein Opel.
sei der Patient
eine OP durchgeführt.
Im Kindesalter
erfolgte eine rechtseitige
Hernehyo-Hernie.
Rechtseitige Hernehyo-Hernie.
Ja.
Im Kindesalter erfolgte eine
rechtseitige Hernehyo-Tomy.
Rechtseitige Hernehyo-Tomy.
Bei Inguinal-Termin.
Gut.
Und
der Patient wurde 3-mal
ein Doskopie durchgeführt.
Er wurde 3-mal ein Doskopie durchgeführt.
Und in diesem Zeit
wurde bei ihm
ein Doskopie durchgeführt.
Der Vorgeschichte
versteht
ein rezipierender
Doskopie.
Diesbezüglich erfolgten bisher
3 Gastroskopien
oder Gastrodiodenoskopien.
Oder ÖGD.
Die Behandlung
erfolgte jeweils Medikamentös.
Ja, genau.
Diese Krankheit sei schon erfolgreich.
Medikamentös behandelt worden.
Okay.
Und der Patient
habe keine Allerke.
Die Frage nach Fiber, Stilfrost
wurden herneins.
Und der Patient
sei
ein Schädter
oder
ein Schädter.
Er macht alles beruflich.
Straßenbau.
Der Patient ist
von Beruf Straßenbauer.
Die Arbeit wird als sehr schwer beschrieben.
Die Arbeit ist körperlich anstrengend.
Gibt es sonst Risikofaktoren bei den Patienten?
Risikofaktoren.
Vielleicht, ja.
Vielleicht, der Patient könnte
Pynomoconiod inhalieren.
Gibt es Risikofaktoren bei Genussmitteln
bei den Patienten?
Ach so, ein Schindel.
Der Patient rauche
ein Schachtel täglich seit 30 Jahren
jeden Abend und ein Schnaps pro Tag.
Einige Schnäpse.
Der Patient hat ausgeprägte
persönliche Risikofaktoren.
Es besteht ein
fortgesetzter Nikotin-Abdosis.
Und Alkoholkonsum.
Bis ins 30 Package hier ist.
Und darüber hinaus besteht ein erheblicher
Alkoholkonsum.
Ein erheblicher, chronischer Alkoholkonsum.
Mindestens 2 Flaschen Bier pro Tag
und mehreren Schnäpsen.
Erheblicher Alkoholkonsum
und mehrere Schnäpsen.
Gibt es Auffälligkeiten in der Familie
in Anamnese?
Ja, in der Familie in Anamnese
fanden sich
eine Diabetes-Melutostypt 2
bei der Mutter.
Und die Mutter sei
eine Kulistik-Tomy
durchgeführt worden.
Und bei der Vater
sei ein Magenkrebs
eine Diabetes-Melutostypt 2
und sei ein Magenkrebs gestorben.
Ja, der Vater
ist im Alter von 60 Jahren,
sehr jung,
einen Magenkarzinom
verstorben.
Die Mutter
ist 86, glaube ich.
Die Mutter lebt noch,
ist 86 und leidet an
einem Diabetes-Melutostypt 2.
Und vor 20 Jahren
wurde sie erfolgreich
scholezistektomiert.
Gibt es Geschwister?
Ja, er habe eine Schwester,
die an Mama Karzinoma
gelitten habe.
Aber dann
sei sie erfolgreich
operiert worden
und er habe
Chemotherapeut bekommen.
Die 52-jährige Schwester
bei der
52-jährigen Schwester
wurde vor einem Jahr ein Mama Karzinom
diagnostiziert.
Dies wurde operiert
und mit Chemotherapie behandelt.
Bisher erfolgreich.
Was ist Ihre Verdachtdiagnose?
Die an einem nächtlichen Angaben
deuten auf eine Akkus-Abdomen
im Rahmen einer
Medizinerie-Infarkt-Chin.
Die Alternative kommt
mit einem Karzinom,
den Magenkarsinom oder
Darmkarsinom,
oder Urkustuodoni,
Urkustventurkuli,
Akkurtus pancreatitis
oder
Infrage.
Wie beginnt die Perforation?
Es kann eine Perforation
aufdrücken.
Es handelt sich um das Bild
eines Akuten-Abdomens.
Man kann eine Lampe anmachen.
Das schneidet das Bild lang.
Man muss
die Schmerzattacken
innerhalb der letzten 3 Jahre,
über eine Gewichtsabnahme
von 8 kg, berichtet.
Wie würden Sie das
tun?
Das heißt,
die B-Symptomatik ist positiv.
Es könnte sein,
dass der Patient
unter einem
Krebs leidet.
Deswegen
verschlechtet
die Symptome.
Ich glaube,
von der Anamnese her,
denke ich eher daran,
dass der Patient
einen Akuten-Schub einer chronischen
Erkrankung hat.
Diese Pankreatitis
gründet sich auf den Alkohol-
Nikotinkonsum.
Er hat zwar
rezidivierende Ulceradodini.
Die passen auch in das Bild
des erhöhten Alkoholkonsums.
Vor 2 Jahren begann diese Phase
und hat sich die Auszahlung
in den Rücken verspült.
Die Stetige
Gewichtsabnahme
ändern
ihr Nahrungsverhalten.
Sie essen viel weniger
vitaminhaltige Dinge.
Sie nehmen oft an Gewicht ab.
Ich glaube,
er kommt dazu,
sich zu entwickeln,
dass Alkoholkonsums ein Faktor ist.
Der Patient hat viele Risikofaktoren.
Nikotinabusos, Alkohol,
sicherlich ein sehr anstrengender
Beruf.
Von der Klinik her, von den Schmerzen
zu der Erkrankung der Pantreatitis.
Der Alistische
Stül war vor einem Tag.
Deswegen dachte ich, dass der Patient
ein medentarial Infarkt hat.
Kann natürlich auch sein.
Aufgrund eines Krebs.
Es wären vielleicht
Symptome bei der körperlichen Untersuchung zu sehen.
Vielleicht hat der Patient leichte Entzug-Symptome.
Der Schmerz hat keinen Alkohol getrunken.
Aber das würde den Rahmen
etwas zu sehr ausdehnen.
Der medentarial Infarkt
ist auch eine Möglichkeit.
Aber von der Häufigkeit her, glaube ich,
und von der Anamnese
würde ich eher Richtung einer Pantreatitis denken.
Oder vielleicht ein gedeckt perforiertes
Ulkustudeni in der Richtung.
Klar, da muss man auch dran denken.
Aber es ist in dem Bauch oben
viele Ursachen möglich.
Die Anamnese
finde ich systematisch erfasst.
Bei der Vorstellung
konsequent noch mal versuchen, umzusetzen.
Die medizinische Sprache.
Sie sagten, anfangs der Patient stellt sich
wegen starker Bauchschmerzen vor.
Klar, das kann man sagen.
Aber man sollte dann sagen, in der Vorstellung beim Oberarzt,
der Patient stellt sich wegen starker, abdomineller
Schmerzen vor,
die seit ca. 10 Stunden bestehen
und die sich aufgebaut haben.
Das wird sich dann versuchen zu sagen.
Das andere haben sie, denke ich, gut gebracht.
Ich habe extra das Kahnbein mal genommen.
Weil das Kaphoid ist nicht immer selbstverständlich.
Versuchen Sie dann einfache Sätze zu machen.
Ich habe extra gesagt beim Fußball spielen.
Da würde ich ruhig sagen,
der Patient erlitt eine Handworzel.
Das ist eine Handworzel.
Das ist eine Handworzelfraktur.
Das ist ein Kaphoid.
Anlässlich einer Sportverletzung.
Ein Sport bedingt.
Dann ist das eigentlich gut.
Diese Faktur wurde erfolgreich operiert.
Oft wird es hier nicht anfangs operiert.
Wenn sie gut heilt, ist es gut.
Aber wenn sie nicht heilt, muss man wahrscheinlich operieren.
Bei diesem Knochen.
Denken Sie an die leistende Herr Nier.
Herr Nier Inguinalis.
Oder Inguinal Herr Nier.
Und es erforderte da eine Herr Neotomy.
Gut.
Dann würde ich sagen,
haben wir das für heute.
Nächste Woche Donnerstag.
Können Sie das mit dem Motivator mitteilen?
Ja, natürlich.
Nächste Donnerstag um 18 Uhr.
Ich habe mir noch ein Tschüssing gemacht.
Vielen Dank.
Ich wünsche euch einen guten Abend.
Und weiterhin gutes Üben.
Danke Ihnen.
Tschüss.